c'est au ski
et bien sûr je viens tu crois quoi que
j'avais planté j'ai toujours rêvé de
faire ça j'ai pas pu m'empêcher une
sorte de test de la mise cette fois que
c'est comme ça qu'ils ont testé la
mission se stresse pas l'amitié des
vivres j'ai juste envie de pouvoir
rigoler un peu moi j'avais envie de
dormir tu vois il est couché
c'est exactement comme ton pote les
banques incapables d'engager dans quoi
que ce soit usma ris orangis crâne mais
bon voilà salma d'être clair
que toi tu as l'air passer les trains
des leds le 31 décembre tu fais quoi
je te dis vite philips t'inquiète pas tu
entends demain matin ça m'ira très bien
ok
ça va super a même quitté qu'est ce que
je te dise mais non des enfants fait
tout ce qu'elle veut quoi faut toujours
faire des gosses si ça va il ya
suffisamment donné bronzer sur terre sa
peine d'en rajouter toujours être
précurseur m dans l'échec
tu peux rentrer la tête je te jure mois
un coût des tentes ou à tout va bien
regarde les abus soit
je vote culture depuis toujours des amis
des vrais toile un beau coup
qu'est ce que tu as été question le
aujourd'hui on n'a qu'un dans sa vie
les deux clowns heures vous les mettez
en cellule de dégrisement serait allé
détendre voilà ce serait possible de
prendre deux chambres séparées